hat die mehrheit immer recht eine frage
die in der politik immer wieder mal heiß
diskutiert wird umso heftiger nach
abstimmungen über umstrittene
volksinitiativen stichwort
masseneinwanderung stichwort
ausschaffung von ausländischen
straftätern oder bau von minaretten
wie aber die meinung der mehrheit
schließlich umgesetzt wird das ist ja
der eigentliche knackpunkt in
politischen prozessen sich radikal
mehrheitsbeschlüssen unterziehen
das tut seit drei wochen eine junge frau
im internet unter dem namen boney m
sie lebt zurzeit direkte demokratie
demokratie ein thema für die
politikwissenschaftlerin regula henkel
und den journalisten daniel binswanger
sie knüpfen sich die mehrheit vor das
gespräch führt norbert bischoff berger
früher war das so in der familie gab es
einen fernseher
dann musste man sich entscheiden ob man
jetzt denn creme oder schaut man den
fussball mord die mehrheit hat bestimmt
wann waren sie denn das letzte mal in
der minderheit
[Musik]
denkbar wäre also ich bin jetzt
professorin und unterrichte studierenden
und dann finde ich mich als in der
minderheit nicht vor mir stehen vor dem
publikum vor den studierenden aber da
wird ja nicht abgestimmt habe ja auch
das sagen in dem sie kann ich natürlich
auch den ton angeben
im fernsehen war es früher auch sagt wir
sind drei kinder zusammen dass ich habe
zwei geschwister
und da diese situation kenne ich von
sponsoren da höre zwar schauen und wir
hatten auch nur einen fernseher
wir haben gesagt das thema vorgenommen
hat die mehrheit immer recht und da ist
die frage wie ist das gefühl der
minderheit oder wenn man in der
minderheit ist
ich habe ihn zwar in der demokratie
gehört dass er dazu dass die mehrheit
bestehen jedenfalls die zahlenmäßige
mehrheit an denn die mehrheit auch immer
recht
nein ich glaube
das ist vollkommen klar die mehrheit hat
bei weitem nicht immer recht und das ist
auch an einer ganz wenigen punkte über
den sich eigentlich alle
auch in der schweiz vollkommen einig
sind es geht ja immer schon daraus
hervor dass alle parteien in unserem
system immer mal wieder verlieren es
gibt niemanden der sich immer durchsetzt
das heißt alle parteien sind in
einzelnen sachfragen auch immer wieder
der ansicht das was die mehrheit
entscheidet ist falsch sonst hätten sie
sich ja nicht für die gegenposition
engagiert aber sie akzeptieren dann dem
mehrheitsbeschluss also die mehrheit hat
nicht immer recht aber
mehrheitsbeschlüsse beispiel beispiel
sie können irgend eine volksabstimmung
nehmen in der schweiz ist das ja
besonders deutlich nicht mit den
initiativen und referenten nehmen wir
etwas besonders aktuelles die
masseneinwanderung initiative 49 7
prozent waren dagegen
50,3 ich wollte zeigen dass wir eine
ganz knappe mehrheit
die aber tatbestände schafft aber
trotzdem finde ich ist das eine gute
frage und ich finde es richtig dieses
gespräch bei dieser frage zu beginnen
aber trotzdem die initianten würden doch
sagen nein wir haben recht wir haben
dieses anliegen haben wir portiert und
die bevölkerung hat uns recht gegeben
ganz genau
das heißt wir haben mehrheits entscheide
die teilweise sehr knapp sind und aus
diesem mehrheit entscheiden wird dann
ein volkswille konstruiert und das ist
ein sehr ambivalent ist und eigentlich
ungenaues kommen als sie sind der
professorin für
kommunikationswissenschaft an der
universität in freiburg in der schweiz
aber auch politikwissenschaftlerin von
haus aus
wie sehen sie das recht haben hat für
mich auch mit legitimität legitimation
zu tun also das was entschieden wird
gehört bei masseneinwanderung initiative
zum beispiel wird dann doch akzeptiert
auch von der minderheit und das sehe ich
als sehr wichtigen punkt also es ist ja
so in der schweiz dass das prozedere
häufig ist und dass das auch akzeptiert
wird und weil der entscheid an als
legitim wahrgenommen wird denke ich in
dem sinn hat die mehrheit recht
wir sind mitten in der politik gelandet
wir wollen aber erstmal mit dem alltag
anfangen sie sind ja redaktor beim das
magazin
der wöchentliche beilage die auch dem
tages anzeiger beiliegt haben sie eine
wöchentliche kolumne sie gehören auch zu
den bloggern also zu leuten die es geht
mir im internet äußern
fangen wir mal an mit dieser frage hat
die mehrheit immer recht so im alltag
und kommen dann zum politischen system
noch mal der schweiz zurück da gab es
jetzt ein experiment der kulturplattform
von srf hat leonie maier die bloggerin
boney m sich einem experiment gestellt
sie hat mal drei wochen lang bis heute
sich eben abstimmung gestellt gesagt
bestimmt ihr was ich im leben mache ich
habe sie getroffen und gefragt was wir
mit dem experiment ergeht die angesagte
bloggerin war das online experiment drei
wochen lang lebt sie die direkte
demokratie
online gehen und abstimmen ihre
entscheidung kommen kaffee trinken oder
rechts und links und hier entscheidet
was ich mache das ziel ist klar
boney m will denkprozesse und
diskussionen anregen und ihre blogger
gemeinde aufzeigen dass politik schon im
alltag anfängt und sogar spaß machen
kann
juni mario was ist das für ein gefühl
fremd bestimmt zu werden haben sie schon
eine identitätskrise
nein eine identitätskrise nicht ich weiß
ja dass das von außen bestimmt ist und
dass das zeitlich begrenzt abläuft aber
es ist ungewohnt
ungewohnt ist das leben verliert an
spontanität und und man kann sich dinge
die sonst automatisch passieren wie ich
weiß ja was ich morgen to unbewusst und
dass das verliert sich also die die
spontanität fällt weg und und man wird
sich war bewusst wie automatisch man
eigentlich funktioniert im alltag gehört
es zum wesen der demokratie
fremdbestimmt zu werden
ich persönlich bin der meinung dass das
so ist ja also ich glaube dass
demokratie auch fremden stimmung ist in
einer natürlich mit mit dem mit dem
grundgedanken eines eines positiven
miteinanders mit eines konstruktiven
miteinanders aber ich habe eine stimme
von vielen und und das gros oder die die
fremde bestimmt was was mit mir passiert
meine eine stimme bestimmt nicht was
politisch mit mir passiert und ich
glaube man kann demokratie auch aus
fremdbestimmung bezeichnen ja ja
fremdbestimmt werden ein experiment in
der minderheit sein wie ist dieses
gefühl können sie das nachvollziehen
mich hat überrascht dass das direkte
demokratie so fest jetzt im zusammenhang
zur fremdbestimmung gebracht wird weil
ich eigentlich vom prozess hält denke
dass das er gerade die gelegenheit werde
mit zu bestimmen
also auch das normative ideal vielleicht
das da am besten dahinter steht bei den
demokratie theorien kann man also gibt
es ja unterschiedliche ansichten was
demokratie sein soll es gibt da unter
anderem partizipatorische ideale also wo
man diese mitbestimmung auch maximieren
möchte dass viele teilnehmen
ich sehe dieses experiment auch ein
bisschen in diesem zusammenhang das
möchte die leute animieren teilzunehmen
ob das gelingt oder nicht dass er möchte
ich jetzt hier nicht diskutieren aber
vor diesem ideal hier also so gesehen
ist das teilt das auf mit wichtig und da
zählt es auf mitbestimmung ab was geht
ihnen durch den kopf
naja ich glaube regiert werden es bis zu
einem gewissen grad immer daran bestimmt
werden und worum es geht in
demokratischen herrschaftsformen das ist
diesen effekt des fremdseins so klein
wie möglich zu halten indem man den
leuten eben die möglichkeit zur
partizipation gibt in dem man den
geltenden regeln eine möglichst hohe
legitimität gibt aber es ist vollkommen
klar außer wenn wir die totale anarchie
leben bedeutet zusammenleben immer dass
man sich an vorschriften halten die
haben vielleicht nicht passen die anti
held wird ja nicht passend jan in diesem
sinne vorgeschrieben werden oder dass
man eben dinge akzeptieren muss die man
vielleicht nicht wählt also regiert
werden ist fremdbestimmt sein ganz egal
wie das system aussieht und die
demokratie da habe ich mache mein
anspruch dass diese fremdbestimmtheit
kleiner ist als in jeder anderen
regierung vor und ich denke dass das
experiment lebt ein bisschen vom vom
reality tv effekt man mischt sich da ins
privatleben der jungen frau man darf da
mitreden mitgucken mitmachen hat man
nicht man teilen dingen die
normalerweise nicht politisiert sind und
das ist ja auch einer der gründe weshalb
alle demokratien normalerweise genau das
zu vermeiden
eben damit die leute nicht dieses gefühl
der entfremdung haben
das heißt es wird in einer demokratie
immer auch ein bereich der privatheit
abgegrenzt von dem man sagt dass es
keine politische frage wie ich das
entscheide das gegen man etwas an die
tafel was dieses pony dem experiment
eben zeigt ist wie wichtig das ist
denn wenn wir darüber abstimmen ob nun
jemand eine pizza oder einen apfel ist
ja dann haben wir ein problem
also ich sehe das experiment auch als
psychologisches experiment ist das für
mich ein bisschen mehr oder werden dass
er als ein demokratisches oder ein
politisches experiment die frage jetzt
sollen sie eben einen apfel essen oder
eine pizza ist da denke ich können die
leute mit treten und da ist die form
jetzt für dieses psychologischen
experiment vielleicht auch kosten dass
man einfach klickt und sagt jetzt soll
sie mal den apfel essen da hab ich ja
auch eine meinung dazu
ich sehe das problematische bei
schwierigeren fragen wo man sich
informieren muss und wo man auch gehabt
wo man sich informieren müssen wenn man
einfach so abstimmt denke ich hat nicht
aber nicht alle dann eine unversehrte
meinung abgegeben oder eine informierte
meinung
da würde ich sie eben als professorin
für kommunikationswissenschaft
rückfragen sie beschäftigen sich sicher
auch mit dem internet das ist ein teil
ihrer forschungsarbeit
sie haben geforscht über verhalten
vorabstimmung also welche informationen
werden da wie transportiert durch die
medien aber auch im internet jetzt aber
mal generell gefragt das internet profil
gebootet gelegt wird treppe zur
demokratisierung bei oder ist das was
ganz anderes
ich glaube nicht dass es primär jetzt
viel veränderung bringt für die
demokratie oder sowie die mechanismen
einlaufen ich glaube sie ergänzen es am
besten also direkte demokratie in der
schweiz ist sehr routiniert dass es die
leute die damit machen die
wie das geht die haben erfahrung also
wenn sie ein thema aufbereiten dann
wissen die was für argumente die leute
verstehen was welche ankommen und wie
sie vielleicht auch die leute überzeugen
können also sind machen sich vorher auch
gedanken und verbreiten dann diese
botschaft in verschiedenen kanälen und
unter das wird ist das internet aber nur
ein kanal richtig oder vielleicht in
denen der seit den 90er jahren sicher
ein bisschen wichtiger geworden oder so
aber nicht das wird dann also die medien
die die klassischen medien sind
letztendlich die transporteure die
botschaften und wenn eine botschaft es
nicht in die medien schafft dann kommt
sie nicht dann ist das leitungs grad
einfach geringer also die muss in die
medien kommen und von daher also
interessant oder seit sie sagen in die
klassischen medien das ist ein
ergebnisse ihrer forschung weil wir
hätten wohl gedacht dass die verfügbar
verfügbarkeit von informationen auch
dazu führt eben die gewohnheit im
internet zu informieren dass ich das da
hin verlagert ich glaube diese
entwicklung ist sehr schwierig zu
beurteilen wie sehr sie tatsächlich die
öffentliche politische debatte verändert
hat ich glaube aber auch dass stimme ich
hab so bitter war ein kläger ein es wird
überschätzt es wird bis anhin massive
geschätzt gerade in den medien selber
setzt man ja nun sehr starken auftrag
über facebook oder twitter
es steht mehr oder weniger explizit
erwartungen raum dass social media also
das funktionieren der öffentlichkeit
vollkommen verändern werden punktuell
spielen social media sich auch eine
rolle man nicht beispielsweise beim
arabischen frühling hat man von der
facebook revolution gesprochen
das war maßlos übertrieben eine
revolution kommt nicht einfach in gang
weil ein paar junge leute auf facebook
kommunizieren aber es hat eine gewisse
rolle vergleichbarer weise sehen wir in
der schweiz angels können sich dieser
mittel benutzen können auf diesem weg an
ein spezialisiertes publikum ihre
botschaft vermitteln also in nischen der
politischen kommunikation können solche
neuen kommunikationsmittel eine wichtige
rolle spielen aber grundsätzlich habe
ich frau eigentlich vollkommen recht
nichts das sind die massenmedien die
wirklich das spiel entscheiden
es sind die klassischen medien und in
diesem bereich und das entspricht
widerspricht dann die vollkommen den
erwartungen die wir von zehn jahren an
sind dann etappen hat im gegenteil das
internet zu einer stärkeren
konzentration geführt wenn sie die
schweizerische medien landschaft
betrachten dann sieht man einerseits
dass die zahl der bringt titel abnimmt
das heißt im pressebereich findet ein
konzentrationsprozess stadt aber noch
viel stärker ist der
konzentrationsprozess bei den online
medien es gibt in der schweiz nur eine
handvoll relevanter online newssites sie
bewegen sich in beiden welten oder in
einem klassischen medium sie schreiben
sie sind aber auch im internet unterwegs
und sozialen medien wenn da mal ein mann
sagte im südwesten über sie hereinbricht
weil die meisten finden jetzt in der
minderheit mit seiner meinung
wie ist das für sie in diesen beiden
welten
ich weiß nicht ob ich in beiden welten
bin denn wir betreiben zwar beim magazin
einen blog aber da ist ja angedockt an
ein klassisches medium nicht dass es ist
ja nicht so dass ich das nun in meiner
ecke auf facebook betreiben würde
abgekoppelt von von einem klassischen
medien titelt aber sicherlich was
zunimmt ist die wichtigkeit von
leserreaktionen also stichwort steuern
nicht dass man halt etwas online stellen
kann um dann hat man unter umständen
sofort sehr viele teilweise auch sehr
heftige reaktionen
ich glaube auch dieses phänomen ist
ambivalent einerseits ist es natürlich
sehr sehr positiv zu bewerten dass
dieser ein baum verkehr der politischen
kommunikation über die klassischen
medien nun brauchen wir aufgebrochen
wird es ist sie nicht mehr nur die
journalisten sich an die leser den
sondern es sind die leser die
intervenieren können die sich auch die
journalisten denken können die autoren
intervenieren können das wird sehr sehr
viel dialogischer das ist grundsätzlich
positiv
andererseits hat es natürlich auch
problematische folgen nivellierung die
erste problematische folge die ich
nennen wörter ist die tatsache dass wir
medienmenschen immer besser wissen was
wie ankommt und ich bin der überzeugung
dass das die medien dazu einlädt
immer mehr sich auf skandal themen zu
stürzen
denn sobald wir sehen sofort aber eine
geschichte einschlägt oder nicht die wir
auch schon darüber sie nicken genauso
das ist für mich ein anderer typ von
debatte beim bei den abstimmungen haben
wir eine debatte die nur zwei lager
involviert sind also die kämpfe um das
beste argument und uns am schlusstag um
mehr asiaten haben sie auch in diesem
großen band herausforderung demokratie
von lars müller einen artikel
geschrieben und da geht aus erd dass das
eigentlich gut funktioniert und ich
vorabstimmung werden die argumente recht
gut in den klassischen medien falsch
wiedergegeben
die gratiszeitung kommen nicht gut davon
das sind die dann einseitig oder nein
also es gibt zweiseitige debatten das
sind die direkte demokratie gehört dazu
wird zwei lager sich gegenseitig
konkurrenzieren und die die
gratiszeitung schlechter weg weil die
einfach weniger ressourcen und die ganze
thematik weniger abhängen also da würde
ich mich nicht informieren wollen oder
nicht das volk informiert haben wollen
nur über 20 minuten bei abstimmungen
es ist einfach quantitativ weniger ja
und qualitativ also das sichert und also
das ist auch von hans-peter krise auch
noch vergeben worden
im rahmen von unserem nationalen
forschungsschwerpunkt aber jetzt die
anderen schützen und die skandale sind
andere début nur eine seite frauen
involviert wird oder oder ist also
diejenigen die den skandal im fünften
leder reisten und die gegenpartei ist
nicht vorbereitet sei also das sehe ich
als ganz andere konstellation es sind
dann nicht institutionelle mechanismen
unter leuten in meinem konto schon
voraussagen aber es ist dann überrascht
da denke ich also ist alles viel und
separat die qualität sicher auch
schlechter moniert einseitig informiert
und eben ein zweiseitiger
informationsfluss ist sehr wichtig für
die meinungsbildung dafür ist emotional
das kann aber ein zweiseitiger
informationsfluss auch sein wenn das
thema der abstimmung im nutzer mal ist
ja ich möchte mich den anschluss nicht
da wir verstehen einfach immer mehr fest
dass das skandale gibt ja eine ungeheure
dynamik entwickeln das letzte beispiel
in der schweiz war der die carlos affäre
die einer der größten
die skandale der straftäter carlos
dieser jugendstraftäter mit dem
sonderseite das war einer der größten
skandale der schweizerischen medien
geschichte wenn man die bewirtschaftung
sie intensität also alkohol wenn man das
ansieht das ist der absolut phänomenal
um er wohl dank ihr ausgelöst durch
einzufahren nicht das waren ich stand
schon all ist er ja das recherchiert hat
sondern es war jemand der eben gesehen
habt von schweizer fernsehen wurde ein
dokumentarfilm über diesen fall
ausgestrahlt da waren informationen
dringen von ländern ein journalist beim
blick die rechnung machte das sind
skandalöse zahlen und der hat dann auf
diesem weg eine unglaubliche lawine
losgetreten nicht mit der niemand
gerechnet hat und ein element bei
solchen phänomenen wo plötzlich ein
schneeball losgeht ohne dass
irgendjemand generals warum und wie das
hat natürlich auch mit den konkreten
thema zu tun das hat auch damit zu tun
dass dahinter tatsächlich politische
debatten stehen aber es hat eben auch
sehr viel mit dieser neuen medien logik
zu tun die vom internet sehr stark
gefördert
erwarten sie da eine rückwirkung von
dieser schilderung von emotionalisierung
von skandalisierung auf die politik
haben wir sie schon so eine rückwirkung
nein ich denke dass einfach diese solche
debatten heikel sind also was das für
folgen hat weiß man vielleicht weniger
da kommt es auch mehr auf die medien
darauf haben also was die da machen und
da können wir haben vielleicht auch mehr
potenzial einzugreifen aktiv
da glaube ich es hat schon rück
wertungen natürlich nicht vielleicht
jetzt auf die grundsätzliche politische
debatte aber es hat sehr große
rückwirkungen darauf die politiker
kommunizieren und das hat sehr große
rückwirkungen darauf wie politiker dann
auch mit solchen skandal umgehen weil
sie können eigentlich wenn ein
ein solcher massives kam daraufhin um
die carls geschichte ausbricht wird es
wahnsinnig gefährlich weil sie kennen
eigentlich fast alles nur noch falsch
machen was immer sie tun und wir stellen
das auch hinter in der täglichen arbeit
fest
die königs strategie damit umzugehen ist
eigentlich die abzutauchen
typischerweise wird ein politiker einen
kommunikationsberater anheuern und der
kommunikationsberater wird ihm sagen
entweder gar nicht oder nur ganz ganz
wenig kommunizieren
das heißt es es ist hier ein neues
gefährdungs fällt für die politik
aufgegangen für einzelne politiker die
in das schussfeld des ostens kann da
alles kommen und es wird dann auch sehr
seltsame art und weise kommuniziert
einfach weil die leute sofort dermaßen
in der defensive sehen dass sie
eigentlich nur noch versuchen können
ihre haut zu weiten und die anderen dann
doch informationen sollen ich denke es
braucht vielleicht dann mehr geld
diese kommunikations beraten müssen
bezahlt werden oder es längst auch von
der andern arbeit also da sehe ich auch
noch glück ihr tun und absolut ist ein
riesiges problem der verdrängungseffekt
nicht wenn wir noch einmal carlos nehmen
man kann diese ganze geschichte
unterschiedlich beurteilen aber was
vollkommen klar ist ist das ein relativ
marginaler einzelfall ist und dass man
nun die ganze schweiz wochenlang sich im
chaos fieber befindet ist ganz egal wie
man das nun bewertet einfach vorkommen
so was ist jetzt ihre sichtbarkeit
natürlich auch sagen das sind allzu
falsch ein und das ganze system so
korrupt ist ja ja aber es sind ja ich
denke dass man also dabei aber nicht
vergessen muss das bei abstimmungen
läuft das grundsätzlich sehr gut
abstimmung finde ich kann man sehr
zufrieden sein so generell das ist etwas
anderes diese skandale oder wenn man
einfach auch über die medien moniert
dass also das abstimmung sind ein
anderer typ skandal
das haben sie auch noch
damit ist schon auch ein bisschen
widersprechen weil system diskussionen
beispielsweise wenn wir nun eine breite
informierte debatte darüber haben wie
funktioniert das jugendstrafrecht was
wollen mehr da ist es gleich zu lax und
so weiter das hat dann am rande schon
auch stark gefunden aber wer in diesen
momenten der hyper skandalisierung sind
diese debatten meistens nicht sehr
tiefgehend und nicht sehr breit weil man
ja nicht wirklich auf den anlegern herz
so sehr gelacht habt ja die anzahl der
artikel die man dann nachweisen kann
genannt gehen wir jetzt vom von der vag
hat die mehrheit recht im alltag zur wir
sind schon hineingerutscht demokratie
zur direkten demokratie in der schweiz
die besser könne ein buch von wolfgang
koydl ist langjähriger korrespondent in
der schweiz für die süddeutsche zeitung
also ein blick von außen und von innen
auf die schweiz
er wird bald zur weltwoche im juli
wechseln
er sagt es gibt weltweit eineinhalb
demokratien die halbe ist sind die usa
und die ganze schweiz seit ich etwas
holzschnittartig gab ein paar hat da
schon vergessen oder er hat also port
vergessen das sind jetzt dort länder wo
es sich am häufigsten vorkommt wobei in
den start untersagt nicht auf nationaler
ebene was man isst aber die schweiz
schon aber trotzdem also das sind zwei
grad zwei spielorten von demokratie die
auch unterschiedlich sind also man hat
dass die gleiche institution und
trotzdem läuft es nicht gleich in der
schweiz ist die direkte demokratie von
den politischen akteuren geleitet die
die etablierten akteure das ist der
bundesrat und die parteien verteilen und
angels und auch andre akteure die
bereiten diese abstimmung vor und
informieren sich auch in den usa wird es
eigentlich geht es darum
dass die macht der parteien im parlament
gerade begrenzt wird und die äußern sich
dann zum beispiel nicht im vornherein
oder außerdem geben keine empfehlung ab
für die abstimmung aber diese direkt
direkte demokratie wie wir sie kennen
das heißt das volk bestimmt das
parlament es stimmt aber auch über
sachfragen gibt sie sonst nirgendwo
nein es gibt es sie in dieser form geben
wie das eigentlich schon ausgeführt hat
auf nationaler ebene tatsächlich
nirgends so trotzdem muss ich sagen dass
diese aussage es gibt nur 100
demokratien auf der welt aus meiner
sicht wirklich eine vollkommene
absurdität erstellt denn man kann und es
gibt viele gründe dafür die direkte
demokratie der repräsentativen
demokratie vorziehen
sie habe präsent aktive werde aber das
volk hin das parlament wählt dann unter
das volk erledigen dann sozusagen fällen
wir in seide und das volk wird nicht
mehr direkt gefragt dass die direkte
demokratie hat eine ganze reihe vorteile
darauf kommen wir vielleicht noch sie
hat auch eine ganze reihe nachteile
ich glaube es sind abwägungsprozess und
was sich immer sehr ärgerlich finde gut
heute als deutscher kann sich das
vielleicht erlauben
deutschland ist ja eine sehr strikte
rein repräsentative demokratie
jedenfalls auf bundesebene was ich sehr
ärgerlich finde ist wenn in der schweiz
so getan wären wert und wir haben immer
mehr tendenz dies zu tun als wären wir
das einzige legitime wirklich
demokratische land der welt das ist
vollkommener unsinn wenn sie sagen der
teuren bundesverfassung steht alle macht
kommt von fackeln und sie haben wunder
prozent legitime obere verfahren wie
diese volksvertretung organisiert werden
england in amerika auf bundesebene ist
es dasselbe und die haben keinen anlass
dies zu verachten
insbesondere auch warum das wort
freiheit ja schon ausgeführt ist ein
ganz wichtiger punkt
der schweiz auch immer mehr
vernachlässigt wird weil eben das
schweizer modell ist deshalb so
erfolgreich und funktioniert so gut da
die schweiz eine mischform von direkter
und repräsentativer demokratie ist und
zwar gerade bei direktdemokratischen
entscheiden das gegenmodell ist
kalifornien wo gewissermaßen die
volksvertreter die parlamente gar nicht
mehr mitreden dürfen wenn eine
initiative kommt die die regierung darf
sich nicht mehr einmischen das parlament
hat sich nicht mehr einmischen
wir haben das genau gegenteil nicht wenn
eine volksinitiative eingereicht werden
so dass der bundesrat stellung nehmen
eine botschaft ausarbeiten da müssen die
beiden räte ist als prozess ein lose
endloses prozedere dass die leute auch
häufig dann enerviert und sie sagen hier
wird der volkswille paralysiert und
jetzt schleppt die sache das warburger
abzocker initiative sehr stark aber
dieses ineinander verzahnen von
repräsentativer demokratie und direkter
demokratie hat ein sehr
funktionstüchtiges system ergeben wären
dem das kalifornische system sich
längerfristig auch sehr sehr schädlich
erwiesen habe ganz einfach deshalb weil
der staat kalifornien pleite gegangen
nur kurzer nachtrag beutel sagen dass
auch es gibt wirklich andere quasi
demokratie in der art wie sie es jetzt
ausgeführt haben ist es einmalig sind
sie da auch ein bisschen stolz dass wir
die direkte demokratie
ich bin stolz und ich finde es auch gut
aber also ich teile die meinung dass man
jetzt nicht überheblich sein sollte oder
dass das überall die richtige lösung ist
also auf was ich achten würde ist dass
man eine kohärenz zwischen werten und
institutionen hat also was die
politische kultur muss zum system passen
und das passt sich in der schweiz sehr
gut das paar genau zu sagen also warum
empfinden wir uns jetzt aus
schweizerinnen und schweizer vielleicht
weil wir den ersten augusttagen die
berge oder so was macht das eigentlich
zu schweizern aber dann sichert das
politische system und die leute
identifizieren sie
im system also das passt sehr gut und
das auf das würde ich auch pflegen wenn
ich in einem anderen land eine
institution bauen müsste was das zu den
lebten post wird das rad wissen vor
nur weil ich den stolz angesprochen habe
die weltwoche sagt zu ihrer kolumne
gedanken schwere depression
intellektueller abscheu jeden samstag
leidet daniel binswanger im magazin
genussvoll an der schweiz
aber es ist elend alles ist vertreten
ein kult gefäß für alle die kleinmütig
noch an die zukunft glauben lesenswert
doch immerhin hören wir als kompliment
aber leiden sie so dieser passus ist mir
gar nicht geläufig zu müssen es gab zehn
kolumnen die sind immerhin sind sie
damit darunter nachher kommt leicht das
wort zum sonntag die man einfach zu
klein ist muss in der schweiz also
dagegen das war dazu am samstag
binswanger aber eben leidet sie an der
schweiz in einigkeit überhaupt nicht an
der schweiz
ich glaube auch dass es unbestritten ist
dass die direkte demokratie ein sehr
gutes system ist so wie es in der
schweiz praktiziert worden ist
ich finde einfach dass wir uns dafür
davor hüten sollten auf andere
demokratien herunter zu sein und in dem
beispielsweise oder andere beispiele für
demokratie nehmen sich nehmen sie
deutschland und wir sollten seit 1945
wohlgemerkt
und wir sollten uns auch denke ich
bewusst sein dass dieses system der
demokratie aufgang der direkten
demokratie wie wir das praktizieren
natürlich auch seine nachteile hat
machen wir beispielsweise den vergleich
mit deutschland oder auch amerika
bleiben wir bei deutschland wenn ich sie
unterbrechen darf joachim gehabt der
deutsche bundespräsident war vor kurzem
da bei uns in der sendung und in der
schweiz und er hat gesagt unter dem
eindruck der masseneinwanderung
initiative direkte demokratie lieber
nicht wir bleiben doch bei der
repräsentativen demokratie wir haben
kurzen haarschnitt vorbereitet wurde es
noch mal eng
die direkte demokratie enthält und birgt
in sich der schöner ansatz der
mitwirkung aller den wir begrüßen birgt
in sich eine große gefahr bei der
richtung bei der herausfinden der
richtung bei hochkomplexen politikthemen
nicht immer gelingt es in der
vorbereitung solche abstimmungen auch
darüber haben wir übrigens in dem
gespräch gesprochen so umfangreich zu
informieren dass jedem wahlbürger auch
die implikationen die durch
internationales recht gesetzt werden
voll bewusst ist wie joachim gauck
anfang april in der schweiz ist die
direkte demokratie zu komplex für die
bürgerinnen und bürger
ich denke nichts gerade derweil die
parteien und die politischen akteure
diese debatten vorbereiten was sie
wählen gewisse dokumente aus und sie
strukturieren die debatte welche themen
oder aspekte eines themas sind wichtig
und die kommunizieren sie dann
ich denke nicht dass es zu komplex sie
haben ja genau darüber gestoßen haben
sie haben darüber geforscht und sie
nicht auch bei forschungen diese
gemeinsam mit hans-peter krise gemacht
haben sind sie doch dann zum ergebnis
gekommen
bei nicht besonders komplexen vorlagen
ist bei debatten über eine
volksinitiative beispielsweise die
debatte relativ vernünftig das heißt sie
präsentiert wirklich starb stamm punkte
aber wenn es sehr komplexe sehr
technische die banken sind
ahv-revision oder
unternehmenssteuerreform sehr
komplizierte geschichten da wird es
schwierig es ist funktioniert da
priorisiert am besten schwierig aber die
medien spielen bei der
unternehmenssteuerreform 2 zum beispiel
auch eine gute rolle also die helfer
noch ein bisschen nacht um damit man das
noch ein bisschen besser versteht aber
es funktioniert noch
sie haben ja den eindruck wenz komplex
wir haben das werber nicht gedeckt und
die branche
das ist dann nicht mehr funktionieren
joachim gauck hätte recht also ich
glaube was gedeckt ist durch die
forschung ist dass es sehr viel weniger
gut funktioniert nicht und die frage ist
wahrscheinlich was erachtet man noch als
befriedigend wenn wir die
unternehmenssteuerreform zwei namen
würde ich sagen ist vollkommen evident
dass es hier zu einer system panne
gekommen ist da wurde gesagt offizielles
wird ein ausfälle von also die steuern
der unternehmen werden gesenkt es werden
ausfälle von ich weiß eine 83 millionen
sein aber eben beide 19 830 ihre so
genau also dass die die rechnungen
präsentiert worden waren auch vollkommen
falsches wurde auch behauptet das ist
eine reform die nur den kmu und den
kleinen betrieben zugute kommt
mittlerweile stellen fest dass es eben
auch dass insbesondere großaktionäre
immense steuerfreibeträge auf dividenden
bekommen das ist den initianten gelungen
all dies und den deckel zu halten
während der ganzen abstimmungs periode
und wie auch immer man sich zu dieser
reform stellt ich glaube hier muss man
sagen das ist immer nicht da wirklich
widerspricht weil wenn der entscheidung
parlament zum beispiel gefällt wurden
worden wäre wäre die informationslage
nicht anders gewesen also da wäre dann
am herzen von den gängigen informationen
damals entschieden worden wurden wurden
das werde wahrscheinlich nicht anders
gewesen
aber ich möchte noch auf etwas anderes
hin weisen das hatte auch eben thema
legitimität man kann an einen entscheid
wegen den prozenten als legitim brachten
oder wegen dem ergebnis und die direkte
demokratie hat ja gerade auch die
qualität dass man es als legitim
erachtet weil man mitbestimmen kann oder
weil das verfahren so ist und das ist
ein unbestrittener rät also was das
sollten wir doch vielleicht auch sagen
das hat so große legitimität und das ist
wichtig für uns dass ein irrtum
angesprochen oder es gibt ein anderes
beispiel habe ich die alten initiative
das weniger verkehr über die alten
rollen sollen dass der verkehr
umgelagert werden soll es gibt viele
andere initiativen entstanden die
weniger verkehr verlangt haben das aber
heißt sich mehr und mehr dass sie nicht
umsetzbar sind die mehrheit hat sich
kreiert sie wurden angenommen sie sind
nicht umsetzbar also bei der umsetzung
ist auch die frage wie groß war die
mehrheit was ich höre auch der bundesrat
vielleicht auch ein bisschen spielraum
oder oder am besten nicht spielen aber
musste er auch in betracht ziehen wie
groß die mehrheit ist und habt
vielleicht am besten spielern dann
stärker oder weniger stark eine
initiative umzusetzen also die abzocker
initiative wurde mit 67,9 prozent
angenommen die masseneinwanderung hatten
sie erwähnt 50,3 also sehr knapp es gibt
andere bisher knapp angenommen wurden
gibt es dann nachher in diesem prozess
der umsetzung das ist aber eine
einschreibung in die verfassung wenn das
zum gesetz wird wird da wirklich dann
gesagt nein moment das war nicht so
viele oder das waren viele also
mehrheitsverhältnisse eine so
entscheidende rolle spielen
sicherlich in dem sehen eher aus über
die frage ist wie stark ist der
politische druck für eine wirklich
buchstaben getreue umsetzung aber die
umsetzung ist ohnehin ein sehr wichtiges
thema und ein thema bei dem ersichtlich
wird dass eben diese volkssouveränität
auch mit puffern ausgestattet ist das
heißt den der umsetzung spielraum den
der bundesrat hat wenn das parlament hat
der führt dazu dass die souveränität die
dem volk im direkten volksentscheid
zugestanden wird bis zu einem gewissen
grad auch wieder zurückgenommen
wo liegt da genau der puffer naja er
liegt eben darin dass wir in sehr vielen
bereichen problematisch umsetzungen
haben umsetzungen die entfernt sind von
den vom ursprünglichen initiativtext und
vor allen dingen liegt der puffer darin
dass es in der schweiz ja keine
verfassungsgerichts
zeit gibt das heißt artikel den der
schweizerischen bundesverfassung stehen
sie nicht bindend für den
gesetzgebungsprozess das parlament kann
theoretisch ein gesetz beschließen das
in vollkommenem widerspruch zur
bundesverfassung steht und das kann
nicht angeklagt werden
es entsteht natürlich ein großer
politischer druck dass man das nicht
allzu offensichtlich tut aber die
möglichkeiten der von regierung und
parlament den volkswillen nicht
umzusetzen sind sehr bedeutend und das
ist das ist als einer der großen
nachteile unserer unserer direkten
demokratie
die verfassung hat in unserem staat
politischen gefüge einen sehr hohen
stellenwert wenn wir das mit dem
deutschen grundgesetz oder mit der
amerikanischen verfassung vergleichen
die ja nun richtig die heiligen texte
sind sagt da sind unsere grundwerte
qualifiziert und die sind einklagbar
und von denen rücken werk einen
fingerbreit ab ich glaube das ist das
ist eine sehr sehr wertvolle politische
institution dass man sich auf diese art
und weise das ständig darüber was sind
unsere werte bevorstehen wie was ist
unverhandelbar
in der schweiz existiert jetzt haben sie
einen nachteil genommen nehmen wir das
beispiel minarett-initiative also es war
keine minarette mehr gebaut werden sagen
einzelne widerspricht der
religionsfreiheit trotzdem die mehrheit
des volkes hat das angenommen jetzt ihr
kollege daniel boxler
politikwissenschaftler sagt dieses
system initiativrecht ist eine
fehlkonstruktion muss revidiert werden
beispielsweise erstens ein starkes
verfassungsgericht soll über die
gültigkeit von initiativen entscheiden
möglicherweise hätte das dann gesagt
innere dienste aktive geht gar nicht
kommt nicht zur abstimmung das parlament
damals andere entschieden
sehen sie das auch so
also ja ich glaube es ist wenn danach
hat er im abstimmungskampf schon gar
nicht klar ist ob das dann überhaupt
umgesetzt wird oder dass man schon denkt
das wird sowieso nicht umgesetzt das
sehe ich als schwierigkeit dass unklar
ist für die entscheidungsfindung also
wenn man dann geht man vom gleichen
dingen aus manche denken vielleicht der
bundesrat setzt das sowieso nicht so
stark um entscheiden aufgrund von dieser
wissens lage-einschätzung und und andere
denken das wird klar umgesetzt das ist
vielleicht heikel ich habe mal in der
schule gelernt dass initiativen werden
da um einen prozess einen
diskussionsprozess anzustoßen aber doch
sicher nicht um die verfassung zu ändern
es wurden ich weiß nicht 180 183
initiativen darüber abgestimmt
inzwischen in insgesamt 20 die
angenommen wurden also zunehmend werden
21 danke zunehmen werden
volksinitiativen angenommen in den
letzten jahren verändert sich etwas
ich glaube das ist ein ganz ganz
wichtiger punkt denn ich weiß nicht wo
wir schweizer besser könner sind aber
wir sind auf alle fälle gut keller oder
vielleicht sehr gut könne das schweizer
system funktioniert und darauf darf man
durchaus auch stolz sein
allerdings müssen wir einfach
feststellen dass eben gerade die
institutionen der direkten demokratie
ungeheuer dynamischen wandel ausgesetzt
sind also direkte demokratie so wie sie
heute in der schweiz funktioniert hat
nur sehr wenig damit zu tun wie direkte
demokratie vor 40 jahren in der schweiz
funktioniert hat und deshalb ist auch
überhaupt nicht in stein gemeißelt
weiterhin eben diese praxis die sich nun
so dynamisch wandelt gute effekte bringt
ob dieses erfolgsmodell erhalten bleibt
oder ob nicht genau diejenigen die
behaupten mit der verabsolutierung oder
der unantastbarkeit der volksrechte
bewahren wir schweizer tradition und
nicht genau diejenigen politischen
kräfte mehr dazu beitragen dass die
schweiz
sich sehr schnell ändert also eine
andere geht es da auch um geld wenn sie
beide sagen ein weiterer nachteil dieser
direkten demokratie in der schweiz ist
die finanzierung die eben nicht
transparent ist also das zeigt auch der
demokratiebarometer dort geht er die
schweiz kommt nicht nur gut oder
zuvorderst das so weg sondern da wird
frauen kritisiert dass die
parteienfinanzierung im transparent ist
und ich finde dass das könnte oder
sollte transparent sein weil das auch
ein hinweis wieder ist für die
stimmbürger und stimmbürgerinnen wer
steckt dahinter wer hat interessen und
das hilft ihnen zwar zu einer besseren
entscheidung zu kommen
da möchte ich mich anschließend nicht
wir haben es gibt eben puffer mit denen
die volkssouveränität relativiert wird
der eine große puffer ist das fehlen von
verfassungsgerichtsbarkeit das heißt was
beschlossen wird hat danach unter
umständen gar nicht so große folgen und
der zweite puffer mit dem dem volk bei
dem durch die macht sein sollte einen
beträchtlichen anteil der macht eben
wieder weggenommen wird das ist die
intransparenz der finanzierung denn es
ist ja vollkommen paradox einerseits ist
unter dem gesichtspunkt der direkten
demokratie die schweiz das
demokratischste land der welt das stimmt
und andererseits ist sie unter dem
gesichtspunkt der völligen intransparenz
der politikfinanzierung das
undemokratische land der welt reist mit
der mentalität zu tun
[Musik]
vielleicht ja also weißt dass nicht über
geld spricht man nicht
gewohnheit und dass es ja vielleicht so
gewachsen ist dass es früher vielleicht
auch weniger geld im spiel war dass man
zuerst einmal hat die direkte demokratie
etablieren musste und das jetzt noch
nicht zu stande kommen vielleicht auch
mit den banken mit dem bank geheimnis
dass viele auch also ich denke dass
mitbewohner zu tun im mentalität
hat aber auch mit den realen
machtstrukturen in unserem land zu tun
denn hanspeter kriesi den wir ja schon
erwähnt haben hat das schlagwort von der
verbands- demokratie geprägt das heißt
er die these aufgestellt direkte
demokratie führt dazu dass das
stimmbürger sich an viele menschen
beteiligen kann
aber das führt nicht primär zu einer
ermächtigung bestimmen bürger sowie des
volkes sondern zu außerparlamentarischen
organisationen die über die
beeinflussung der öffentlichen meinung
sich sehr viel macht sichern können
insbesondere eben zu den
wirtschaftsverbänden
das ist auch historisch vollkommen
evident das referendumsrecht wurde der
18 74 eingeführt in der schweiz und 1882
wurde der damalige vor ort also der
vorläufer des wirtschaftsverbandes
economie suisse dann neu organisiert und
zu einer schlagfertigen schlagkräftigen
lobbying gruppe gemacht und das war der
moment wo der schweizerische wirtschaft
des tablets mit begriffen hat eigentlich
ist die direkte demokratie auch für
jungs sehr nützlich zu beginn haben die
wirtschaftshilfen die demokratie die
direkte demokratie aufs blut bekämpft zu
überlassen
aber dann haben sie gemerkt wir können
auf diesem weg unserer macht ausbauen um
das ist bis heute so geblieben
es würden sicher viele andere sehen die
sagen nein ich habe so abgestimmt ich
möchte er mit der mehrheit dass es so
umgesetzt wird sie sagen jetzt die polit
finanzierung ist so wichtig christoph
blocher hat jetzt gesagt ich gehe aus
der nationalrat aber wenn's sein muss
für die abstimmung wenn es dazu kommt
über die europäische union oder unser
verhältnis zu europa nehme ich gerne ein
paar millionen vielleicht fünf millionen
gehalt sehr offen kommuniziert was würde
denn die transparenz der geldflüsse
bringen
was man eben weiß wer hat welche im
westen beim spiel wie sehen die akteure
auch die konsequenz einer abstimmung
also dass man das hat sie für die
meinungsbildung ich möchte noch an
bedarf greifen ganz demokratie also das
stimmt natürlich jetzt neueste forschung
zeigt eigentlich dass dieser einfluss
wieder ein bisschen kleiner geworden ist
also es wird nicht mehr so ein blog ist
ist uneinheitliche spielt dann dies mehr
diese konkurrenz von einflussreichen
gruppen es wird wieder ein bisschen
interessanter und das sind änderungen im
gang also das ist abgelenkt wurde stand
das zusammen dass die jungen sich nicht
mehr so engagieren den vereinen und
organisationen oder und dran dann
vielleicht dass man weniger im verband
also nicht nur dem freien sonntag mit
dem verbandsstrukturen da so dass das
immer wichtiger geworden ist mit der
globalisierung mediatisierung also
internationale der wirtschaft ja es hat
sicherlich mit dem mit dem gesamten
gesellschaftlichen wandel zu tun nicht
also besonders auf der bürgerlichen
seite die ja immer die finanzstärke
seite war in der schweizerischen politik
haben große umschichtungen stattgefunden
zum einen ist die verbindung zwischen
politischem establishment
unwirtschaftlich man sehr sehr viel los
geworden
ich glaube ein drittel der singles
grosser schweizer firmen sprechen gar
kein deutscher sondern englisch
sie haben mit schweizer politik wirklich
überhaupt nichts am hut aus rheine 7
gerade den regierungsbericht rift der so
etwas angeht da wird dann eine
professionelle pr firma beauftragt und
zum anderen hat sich natürlich auch eine
reorganisation von politischer seite
eingestellt weil früher letztlich eben
dass das milieu der wirtschaftsverbände
das milieu der der bürgerlichen parteien
man war sich sehr nahe
man hatte diese helden politischen ziele
und ideale und da gab es eine ganz
natürliche querfinanzierung heute ist
mit der svp die ebenfalls sehr
finanzstark ist ist da ein neuer player
ins spiel gekommen der diese harmonie
stört und das hat unter dem strich
sicherlich dazu geführt dass die
wirtschaftsverbände nicht mehr dieselbe
macht hat ja von einem hohen anteil an
wählerinnen und wählern gewählt wird wir
sind wieder im alltag zurück
demokratisierung des alltags wir sind da
gestartet über die politik wieder
zurückgekehrt wenn sie so zum schluss
noch mal zurückschauen würden sie sagen
ja ich bin stolz und die schweiz wir
sollten dabei bleiben direkte demokratie
sicherlich wir sollten der wahl bleiben
aber ich glaube dass wir eine tendenz
haben nun immer stärken eine tendenz
haben etwas zu stolz zu sein
es ist ein gutes instrument wir sollten
es nicht absolut setzen wir sollten
verstehen dass direkte demokratie nur im
zusammenspiel mit einer tadellosen
rechtsstaatlichen kultur ihre idee sich
gut entfalten kann und wir sollten
aufhören auf repräsentative demokratie
die es gibt staaten die genauso
erfolgreich sein in den grundwerte sehr
solide verankert sind die auch
wirtschaftlich sehr erfolgreich sind die
keine direkte demokratie haben wir
sollten aufhören latent immer ein
bisschen auf diese staaten dazu
plötzlich ein paar hängt ja was ich
denke die parteienfinanzierung haben wir
angesprochen das könnte ein
verbesserungspotenzial sein und ein
anderer dem jetzt nicht angesprochen
haben aber den ich auch so ist dass man
die parteien die viele wähler anteile
haben dass man die entsprechenden
bundesrat auch vertreten lässt also ich
würde sagen die svp sollte mit zwei
sitzen wieder im bundesrat vertreten
sein weil eben die direkte demokratie
von den politischen akteuren her
gesteuert und auch vorbereitet wird und
das ist finde ich nicht das heißt eine
weitere korrekturen system die sich
anregen
besten dank für diese einschätzungen und
für diese einschätzung kommentare besten
banker bin zwar verhängt
[Musik]
nächsten sonntag gibt es hier bei uns
eine begegnung der besonderen art
charles lewinsky legendärer serien
schreiber und romanautor befragt eine
legende des deutschsprachigen fernsehens
dem talkmaster harald schmidt und darf
gespannt sein was sich die beiden
älteren herren zu sagen haben
jetzt bleiben uns noch 30 minuten für
filmkunst die französisch-schweizerische
regisseurin ursula meier ist bekannt
geworden mit home einem film in denen
die schauspielerin isabelle huppert die
hauptrolle spielt in unserem porträt pin
spielt die regisseurin die hauptrolle